looting america that's the focus of
tonight's angle
so after college football games wrapped
up this weekend i actually hid
the television remotes from my kids i do
that a lot but especially this weekend
because the footage of the flash mobs
looting the stores in the bay area in
chicago and of course the horrific video
of that christmas parade
massacre it's what you have to call it
in waukesha wisconsin it was just too
much ugliness and depravity couldn't
take it
but then i realized of course i have an
obligation
to explain this all to my kids
and so i told them look the stealing is
happening because liberal politicians
have coddled and glorified radical blm
activists who market grievance
and they market resentment nationwide
now remember in the summer of 2020 it
was gavin groveling
for those of you that are out there
protesting i want you to know you matter
and i want you to know
i care we care
you've lost patience so have i
you are right
to feel wronged
you are right to feel the way you are
feeling
oh it's just like you want to take a
shower after watching him and who can
forget san francisco's mayor london
breed her push for a
million dollar cut from the police
budget
by the way for this she was profiled in
vogue magazine
now when reality hit she pulled back on
that idiotic idea
i was thinking it's funny how thieves
aren't trying this same nonsense in
states like florida or texas instead
they're targeting the bay area with
marxist da's like
chesabuddin and big cities like chicago
run by corrupt mayors like lori
lightfoot
organized criminals and petty thieves
know that the chances of being
apprehended and actually prosecuted in
these cities are slim to none
so 17 months after the unchecked mayhem
from the george floyd riots
stealing couldn't be easier
slap on a coveted mandated face mask
pull a hoodie over your head have a car
waiting you're good to go
now under the circumstances created by
local incompetence
the police are either being branded as
racists or cornered by vaccine mandates
the pro-criminal soros supported da's
the unspoken belief that police just
shouldn't respond aggressively to
property crime now all of this means
it's open season on retail chains just
trying to get back on their feet
and the murderous thug who mowed through
the parade
well he should have never been on the
streets at all
he had just smashed the mother of his
child in the face
ran part of her leg over and was already
out on some low bail amount
now unless you think he was just having
a rough month his rap sheet spans
decades everything from felony
strangulation charges to aggravated
battery oh he's also a registered sex
offender in nevada no big deal
so after all of this
including the start of an internal
review by the milwaukee d.a
to find out why this sugg was out on
such low bail
well squad leader aoc
she wants to make things even easier for
criminals
she's going after what's called
excessive cash bail
unbelievable you cannot make this up now
of course the regime media they move
quickly to discount even the possibility
of any political motive on the part of
that thug but his lousy rap music is
rife itself with violence
mother suckers listen put them in the
field we blitz them shoot out all the
ammunition they move like some
caterpillars post this on your social
feed andy's that extend release too
simple your talk is cheap i won't stop
till you disease well the lyrics if you
can call them that are all about fury
and revenge the n-word scattered through
yeah but it's all healthy
self-expression we'd be told in a
college seminar on hip-hop
now of course hollywood or schools even
corporate america they're in a constant
state of apology over america's past and
present
so they've lionized colin kaepernick
so-called anti-racism the blm movement
and life in our country we're supposed
to believe
is vicious it's unfair it's racist and
it's rigged
you go on social media and you're
actually going to see people tonight who
have fancy titles next to their names
making excuses for looting
we're entitled to what you have you
didn't build that you don't deserve that
you're living on stolen land you're
racist blah blah blah goes on and on
it's even called consumer
reparations
you will not and must not stop them for
if you do they will cry racism they will
even cry racism if no black person was
involved in a high-profile case
i find these people disgusting ellie i'm
disgusted at what i'm seeing it's not
just this trial it's other trials but
this in particular the fact that white
supremacists roam the halls of congress
freely and celebrate this little
murderous white supremacist and the fact
that he gets to walk the streets freely
it was an injustice this was worse than
the immiguel trial this idea of
white vigilante violence
where white men feel that they have the
right to enforce the law themselves
there is a dark edge of people
celebrating this
of course that's all about the
rittenhouse trial and verdict
and yes there are connections among the
chaos in the streets after the blake
shooting the multi-day looting spree
and the parade tragedy
all of these scenarios sprang from a
refusal to enforce the laws is written
and the impulse to blame racism as a
convenient cover
as low as biden has stooped these past
11 months he sunk further into the
gutter by leaning into the anger of the
left after the written house verdict
came out
and harris implicitly agreed that there
were racial undertones in written houses
getting off
the verdict really speaks for itself
as many of you know i've spent a
majority of my career working to make
the criminal justice system more
equitable and clearly there's a lot more
work to do
now talk about a hit and run she spews
her acidic accusations about our country
then she scoots away
can't risk being asked real questions by
real reporters can we
now the fact is everything we warned you
about during the 2020 campaign is now
happening to the country we love
we warned you that efforts to defund the
police would lead to fewer cops in more
dangerous streets
we warned you of how coveted shutdowns
and of all the businesses in schools
would hurt not help
we warned you that politicized school
boards would ruin school curricula
we warned you that inflation would be
permanent unless biden left trump's
policies in place
we warned you that race relations would
worsen when frauds tried to turn us
against our own history and traditions
yet
there are encouraging signs that
americans just don't want to live in the
type of society that the democrats
captive to the far left are building for
us
african americans are beginning to leave
chicago
hispanics are voting republican and now
asians
are turning to the gop
more parents are voting with their feet
and their school tuition dollars
so congrats democrats this might be the
last generation of christians who send
their kids to public schools
the left is determined to turn all of
them into woke re-education camps
the world the left is building is
depressing and it's cynical
one where they don't even want
families to have many children anymore
one where their response to every
problem is a
to say america is racist and deserve
whatever happens b
raise taxes and redistribute money to
their cronies or c to encourage
americans to lower their standard of
living and their expectations
the radical movement that the left
started and that the democrats stupidly
adopted
is designed to tear down the entire
country
but now they're beginning to tear
themselves down too look at the polls
one's worse than the next for the
democrats
of course the real victims of the
looting and the lawlessness
aren't the wealthy
it's the people who work in the stores
and own nearby businesses
a lot of these stores won't open again
and why should they
as usual modern day liberalism
sacrifices the middle class for the
whims and convenience of the super rich
next year the democrats non-stop smash
and grab
will finally come to an end though
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else